meine damen und herren auf vielen ebenen
wird gesprochen getagt informiert dass
auch jeder sozusagen die ballhöhe hat
gerade für deutschland ist am wochenende
eine man kann das so sagen eine
kehrtwende eine zäsur eingeleitet worden
die letzten 20 jahre von außen und
sicherheitspolitik sind auf den
prüfstand gestellt worden und werden
wenn denn alles sozusagen im
parlamentarischen prozess dann so
beschlossen wird auch noch einmal massiv
verändert deutschland wird sich stärker
außen und sicherheitspolitisch
engagieren das ist in einer
regierungserklärung des kanzlers olaf
scholz am sonntag durchaus deutlich
geworden heute also ein neuer punkt eine
sondersitzung des auswärtigen
ausschusses in einer plenarsaal freien
woche an einem freitag mit einem
einzigen tagesordnungspunkt nämlich
tatsächlich den bericht der
bundesregierung zu diesen punkt zu den
vorfällen in der ukraine und auch einen
bericht des bundesnachrichtendienstes
das bedeutet die sitzung ist als geheim
eingestuft dass es keine freude für
reporter die das begleiten müssen aber
für erfahrene reporter ist es überhaupt
kein problem und gerd joachim von
fallois ist so ein erfahrener reporter
gert ich grüße sie in die hauptstadt ins
paul löbe haus wenn ich das richtig sehe
hier von bonner sicht und darf sie
fragen was sozusagen vor der sitzung an
äußerung und ein meinungsbild und das
ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
different zu hören war
so ist es die parlamentarier haben
selber diese sondersitzung verlangt sie
wollen vor allen dingen informationen
der geheimdienste haben wie die
situation in russland ist das
interessiert hier besonders und
natürlich in der ukraine
aber vielleicht haben sie es mitbekommen
der bnd präsident bruno kahl war ja beim
tag des kriegsausbruchs in der ukraine
musste dann sozusagen dort fliehen also
die erkenntnisse da werden nicht so groß
sein aber gerade wie die stimmung die
situation in russland ist das
interessiert hier die abgeordneten der
außen- und sicherheitspolitische berater
des bundeskanzlers plötner ist anwesend
und wird auskunft geben aber auch der
staatssekretär aus dem auswärtigen amt
der beamtete staatssekretär michael es
ist heute da und darum geht es eben in
geheimer sitzung danach dürfen die
abgeordneten darüber nichts erzählen
aber vorher haben sie natürlich die
chance wahrgenommen hier vor den
journalisten stellung zu nehmen stellung
zur aktuellen diskussion unter anderem
wie kann es jetzt weitergehen und auch
die frage was bedeutet einen angriff auf
ein atomkraftwerk da gab es ja hier im
politischen berlin schon die heftige
kontroversen ist das jetzt ein fall wo
dann die nato eventuell dann involviert
werden muss das hat für durch märz
angedeutet er hat gesagt der
oppositionschef wenn die russen dazu
übergehen atomkraftwerke anzugreifen und
da irgendwas austritt dann ist das
natürlich auch einen angriff auf die
nato dann müssen wir überlegen ob wir
dann andere schritte einleiten der
bundeskanzler hat ja sowohl gestern in
dem großen interview wie auch heute
morgen dem widersprochen und hat gesagt
also die nato wird in keinem fall
involviert werden und dazu nahm die
abgeordneten hier auch stellung der
erste den wir hören werden ist thomas
rothe ist der vorsitzende des
auswärtigen ausschusses von der spd
ja ich darf sie alle ganz herzlich hier
am paul-löbe-haus begrüßen zu einer
abermaligen sondersitzung des
auswärtigen ausschusses
angesichts der ankündigung des
russischen präsidenten diesen
furchtbaren krieg brutalstmöglich
fortzusetzen haben wir uns entschieden
uns noch einmal mit vertreterinnen und
vertretern der bundesregierung darüber
auszutauschen wie die lage sich
darstellt in der ukraine aber auch in
russland und wie die nächsten schritte
aussehen das wichtigste am anfang
auch wenn die bisher geführten gespräche
nicht danach aussehen es muss zu einem
unverzüglichen
waffenstillstand kommen und das minimum
was zu erwarten wäre es dass es
zumindest während der gespräche die ja
zwischen der russischen und der
ukrainischen seite laufen zu einem
waffenstillstand kommt es ist der
ukrainischen seite sehr hoch anzurechnen
dass sie trotz unzumutbare bedingungen
immer wieder bereit ist auch die
gespräche mit der russischen seite
fortzusetzen es wäre sicherlich auch gut
wenn die russische seite bereit wäre
diese gespräche verbindlicher
fortzusetzen unter leitung eines einer
internationalen persönlichkeit die als
vermittlerin oder vermittler dort
eingeschaltet werden könnte natürlich
müsste diese persönlichkeit sowohl von
der russischen als auch von der
ukrainischen seite akzeptiert und
respektiert werden ich stehe im
täglichen kontakt mit abgeordneten des
ukrainischen parlamentes es gibt klare
forderungen einer der wichtigsten wir
brauchen humanitäre korridore um die
dramatische lage der menschen in der
ukraine
nachhaltig zu verbessern und bislang
reicht es nicht wenn putin nur abstrakt
erklärt darauf könnte man sich
verständigen es ist ein zwingendes gebot
der menschlichkeit und es gibt eklatante
versorgungsengpässe in der ukraine auch
in der hauptstadt vor allem bei den
medikamenten es geht um kinder es geht
um kranke und chronisch kranke die
dringend auf medizinische versorgung
angewiesen sind und es ist auch nach dem
inakzeptablen angriff auf ein
atomkraftwerk vom schlimmsten auszugehen
und auch hier muss man deutlich machen
dass putin zumindestens bereit sein
sollte dass es sicherheitszonen gibt die
auch von ihm anerkannt werden damit es
nicht zu einer weiteren furchtbaren
eskalation mit schlimmsten
unkontrollierbaren folgen
käme wir werden heute das gespräch
suchen vor allem auch mit dem
auswärtigen amt mit dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium mit dem
bundesnachrichtendienst
dass putin sich in die ecke gedrängt
fühlt kann man ja auch daran erkennen
dass nicht nur die sanktionen wirkung
entfalten dass nicht nur der westen
weiterhin geschlossen und entschlossen
ist sondern dass es auch große unruhe in
der russischen bevölkerung gibt und mit
einer weiteren drastischen einschränkung
der meinungs- und medienfreiheit in
russland versucht putin seine
lügenmärchen aufrechtzuerhalten
dass er die ukraine befreit von den
faschisten und faschisten auch das ist
etwas was nach wie vor auch in der
russischen bevölkerung auf verständnis
stößt war es faktisch keinen freien
meinung zu gang und medien zugang mehr
gibt und die menschen nicht mehr die
möglichkeit haben
faktenbasiert sich zu informieren über
die dramatische lage in der ukraine
beim atomkraftwerk ruhe könnte ein
artikel 5 fall für die nato sein wie
sehen sie das ich kann nur dringend
davor warnen jetzt darüber zu
spekulieren
die nato hat in großer einvernehmen
großem einvernehmen entschieden dass man
zwar die ukraine weitreichend
unterstützt humanitär aber eben auch
militärisch und das wird ja auch
fortgesetzt dass ich aber jetzt hier
nicht über bündnis fälle sprechen möchte
die regeln sind sehr klar sollte die
russische seite wirklich ein nato
mitgliedsland angreifen dann stellt sich
der bündnisfall aber alle anderen
diskussionen darüber halte ich zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt für
verantwortungslos wir sollten das lassen
eine frau oder ein mann einzuschalten
ganz konkret sind sie dafür dass alt
kanzlerin merkel als vermittlerin
auftritt es geht hier nicht darum was
die michael roth gefällt sondern es geht
darum was für die russische und für die
ukrainische seite akzeptabel wäre und da
ist natürlich eine erfahrene
persönlichkeit mit diplomatischem
geschick gefragt aber meine erwartungen
sind da sehr bescheiden im prinzip
müsste man sich erst einmal darauf
einigen dass man solche ernsthaften
friedensgespräche wirklich auch sucht
mit dem ziel jetzt einen
waffenstillstand zu erreichen damit das
leid so vieler unschuldiger beendet wird
grundsätzlich ist die bundeskanzlerin
sicherlich mit ihren beziehungen und mit
ihrer erfahrung eine der möglichen
kandidatinnen aber ich will da überhaupt
nicht vorweg greifen ich glaube jeder
name der da jetzt genannt wird ist
möglicherweise ein name der sehr schnell
verbrannt wird und da ich als sehr
parteiisch wahrgenommen werde als jemand
der uneingeschränkt an der seite der
ukraine steht sollte ich mich mit
ratschlägen hier tun dies zurückhaltend
denn jetzt angedacht überhaupt noch
denkbar für die ukraine
also wichtig ist dass die humanitäre
hilfe jetzt auch ankommt und ich erwarte
natürlich auch von der bundesregierung
aber auch von anderen bündnis
partnerinnen und partnern dass wir jetzt
alles dafür tun dass kurzfristig auch
die hilfe da hin kommt wo sie gebraucht
wird da setzt aber eben auch diese
humanitären korridore voraus darüber
hinaus diskutieren wir ja auch wie wir
dem der verteidigung der ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer noch besser rechnung zu
tragen vermögen auch darüber gibt es ja
gespräche ich warne aber dringend vor
einer detaillierten diskussion in der
öffentlichkeit und ich kann mich da
meiner ausschussvorsitzenden kollegen
strack-zimmermann nur anschließen jede
öffentliche debatte darüber was wir an
waffensystemen liefern wie wir liefern
wann wir liefern gefährdet nicht nur
unsere eigenen leute sondern gefährdet
natürlich auch die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer da brauchen wir ein höchstmaß
an diskretion weil wir alle wissen die
nachrichtendienste der russischen seite
funktionieren sehr gut
das atomkraftwerk gibt es jetzt eine
neue risikobewertung auch aufgrund lässt
darüber werden wir sicherlich heute mit
den vertreterinnen und vertretern der
bundesregierung zu sprechen haben aber
selbstverständlich ist dass das ein
weiteres no-go darstellt und man
wiedererkennt dass putin offenkundig
jedes mittel recht ist und dass er immer
wieder auch das internationale recht
bricht ganz bewusst um auch angst und
schrecken die menschen in angst und
schrecken zu versetzen gerade auch die
drohung mit den atomwaffen hat ja auch
bei uns in deutschland und im westen zu
einer diskussion geführt
provozieren wir nicht putin mit unserer
solidarität gegenüber der ukraine und so
sehr ich die sorgen und ängste auch der
menschen in unserem land verstehe möchte
ich hier nochmal klar zum ausdruck
bringen wir dürfen jetzt nicht
nachlassen in der unterstützung für die
ukraine denn das einzige was herrn putin
nicht provozierte wäre das nichts tun
und nichts tun das kann in dieser
dramatischen situation keine option für
deutschland keine option für die nato
keine option für die europäische union
seien
noch ein bündnisfall gleichwohl liefern
aber nato-länder waffen materialien die
ukraine glauben sie wir könnten uns auf
diesem wege doch oder die nato könnte
sich auf diesem wege doch eben
vom verteidigungsbündnis in eine
kriegspartei mit verstricken wir haben
dazu doch klare regeln und an diese
regeln halten wir uns und wir sollten
gar nicht der russischen prammer
propaganda auf den leim gehen die ja
egal was ihr tut sagt wir würden doch
schon längst in diesen krieg in uns in
diesem krieg beteiligen ich halte das
für eine schwierige diskussion ich
glaube dass wir uns genau an die regeln
halten und dass deshalb lehnen wir zum
beispiel ja auch die no fly zone ab weil
sie ja kontrolliert werden müsste und
die kann könnte nur kontrolliert werden
beispielsweise durch nato kräfte und das
wäre derzeit eine beteiligung die wir
ausschließen weil die konsequenzen die
sich daraus ergeben würden
unvorhersehbaren und deswegen lehnen wir
das ab und darüber werden ja sicherlich
heute auch die außenministerin und
außenminister der nato sprechen aber den
kann ich überhaupt nicht vorweg greifen
aber da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher wie
die haltung der bundesregierung aussehen
wird der bundeskanzler hat das ja jüngst
auch noch einmal deutlich zum ausdruck
gebracht wir haben diese ausschuss
sitzung anberaumt war wir uns auf den
aktuellen stand bringen lassen wollen
gerade auch vor dem hintergrund der
ankündigung die man aus dem gespräch von
makro mit putin nehmen muss dass der
krieg dort intensiviert und das heißt
brutalisiert werden soll
das ist der anlass wegen wird diese
sitzung hierdurch
eine vernünftige idee wir haben uns
entschieden in dieser situation
bestimmte waffen die der verteidigung
und dem aufhalten können zu liefern es
wird auch weitere lieferungen geben dass
bundessicherheitsrat wird darüber
entscheiden
ich würde trotzdem von der perspektive
herse folgendes anmerken
diese waffen können eigentlich nur dazu
dienen durch eine verzögerung die
bereitschaft einen waffenstillstand
herbeizuführen zu beschleunigen
vermittler vorgeschlagen und was halten
sie von der idee
ich weiß nicht ob wir einen vermittler
morgen aber wenn es einen vermittler
wenn ein vermittler hilft soll es mir
recht sein mein eindruck ist dass die
nato bis hin zum us-präsidenten es
bisher nicht an bereitschaft hat fehlen
lassen mit der russischen seite zu
sprechen die vorstellung aber dass
während in
der ukraine wohnhäuser mit raketen
beschossen werden man einfach so einen
offenen diskurs führt die geht glaube
ich an verständnis von diplomatie vorbei
voraussetzung für ernsthafte gespräche
ist die einstellung der kampfhandlungen
wir haben auch als cdu csu fraktion
dringend darum gebeten dass diese woche
auch noch mal eine ausschüsse zum
stattfindet das ist aber glaube ich
konsens unter den fraktionen des
bundestages weil ich mir von dieser
sitzung schon erhofft dass wir über die
allgemein zugänglichen informationen
hinaus sowohl über die lage in der
ukraine als auch über die lage in
russland nähere auskunft bekommen wir
beobachten in den letzten stunden in den
letzten zwei drei tagen eine weitere
eskalation des konfliktes die auch
wesentlich damit zu tun hat dass die
russische armee offensichtlich in keiner
weise in der lage ist die erwartung zu
erfüllen die die führung in russland in
sie gesteckt hat das ist einer der
großen fehleinschätzungen putins gewesen
um bei darüber können wir uns nicht frau
hin weil das eben zu dieser situation
führt dass er jetzt eskaliert es wird
zivilbevölkerung im großen stil
angegriffen völkerrechtsverletzungen
liegen meines erachtens auf der hand das
ist dramatisch dass das bereits am
zehnten tag eines solchen krieges
stattfindet und das was wir heute nacht
erlebt haben könnte vielleicht ein ein
bewusstes zeichen putins sein so nach
dem motto wenn ihr nicht spurt wenn die
käfer regierung nicht kapituliert dann
ist man auch in der lage eine atomare
verseuchung der region zu erzeugen indem
man eben dieses kernkraftwerk was man
jetzt besetzt hat
entsprechend hoch gehen lässt das ist
leider eine eine mutmaßung die wir in
diesen zeiten einfach einstellen müssen
weil wir keine andere erklärung für
diese handlung haben und ich glaube dass
wir uns jetzt informieren müssen über
die lage unsere eigene einschätzung
gegebenenfalls prüfen müssen vor den vor
den hintergründen von den fakten und
dass wir vor allem auch in diesen tagen
das humanitäre leid der menschen im
blick haben müssen und die frage wie man
humanitär helfen kann ist für mich auch
eine ganz zentrale ich habe kein
vertrauen in die verhandlungsteams die
dort an der russischen grenze zusammen
sitzen weil ich mir die gesichter
angucke auf russischer seite einen von
denen kenne ich aus dem europarat
da möchte ich mich jetzt nicht zu äußern
was ich von dem halte ich glaube das
sind nicht die richtigen dieser
entscheidung treffen können und die
frage ist ob wir irgendwann an einen
punkt kommen wo wir auch auf höherer
ebene mit russland reden müssen um eine
humanitäre lösung in manchen regionen zu
finden
ansonsten sind wir in einer der extrem
schwierigen außenpolitischen lagen wo
wir aufgrund der unberechenbarkeit des
gegners nur sehr schwer unsere eigenen
handlungen für die zukunft vorhersagen
können
fraktionsvorsitzender gesagt eine
mögliche verseuchung zentraleuropas
könnte nato bündnisfall sein können sie
das erläutern inwiefern das wirklich
eine möglichkeit ist der nato fall
auszulösen also das ist eine bedrohung
der nato wäre wenn wir mitten in europa
radioaktiver verseuchung großen stil
hätten liegt auf der hand die frage ist
ob wir mit unseren mitteln ob wir
geeignete mittel der nato haben um das
dann einzuhegen oder ob eine eskalation
des konfliktes ich bin zum beispiel
davon überzeugt dass die nato
streitkräfte in der lage wären die
russischen streitkräfte in der ukraine
in kürzester zeit konventionell zu
siegen das wir sehen ja dass das
offensichtlich keine große militärische
aufgabe ist aber das würde ja eine
situation erzeugen in der die gegenseite
im zweifel zu weitere eskalation
richtung nuklear
geradezu sich angestiftet fühlen könnte
und wenn man im hinterkopf hat dass
putin ja seit jahren die große
geschichte erzählt dass letztlich die
nato etwas gegen russland hat das ist ja
die legende auf der sein ganzes haus
sein ganzes politisches argumentation
haus aufbaut finde ich sollten wir sehr
vorsichtig sein um hier an dieser stelle
sozusagen propagandistische munition zu
geben ich glaube aber natürlich dass wir
100 prozent klar machen müssen und da
bin ich auch dankbar dass das der
us-präsident ja auch immer wieder so
klar sagt wenn nato territorium von
diesem krieg betroffen wird also wenn
fremde kräfte in das nato territorium
eindringen würden wäre der
verteidigungsfall da und dann würde auch
die gesamte nato inklusive der
bundeswehr wie ein mann stehen ich halte
haben weder noch um putin eventuell auch
zu stoppen ich glaube dass wir die
sanktionsschraube noch nicht weit genug
dreht haben ich kann mir vorstellen dass
wir auf diese eskalation des krieges in
der ukraine mit einer weiteren
verschärfung des ausschlusses russlands
vom swift reagieren könnten ich glaube
auch dass als letztes mittel mit großen
opfern verbunden auch für uns für die
westliche welt aber ich glaube sehr
wirksam wie auch darüber reden müssen
dass wir unsererseits sagen wir beziehen
kein gas mehr aus russland dass amerika
sagt wir beziehen kein öl mehr aus
russland denn das sind viele hundert
millionen dollar die dort quasi täglich
auf legale weise als zahlung für diese
rohstoffe in das land fließen und wenn
der konflikt noch lange weitergeht
müssen wir uns natürlich dann in einigen
wochen und monaten den vorwurf gefallen
lassen ihr habt sozusagen das geld
bereitgestellt was putin braucht um
diesen krieg zu führen um die ukraine zu
unterdrücken deswegen glaube ich dass
als solche überlegungen auch auf den
tisch müssen und dass man diese waffen
den anführungsstrichen also diese diese
instrumente auch offen benennen und
zeigen muss und das ist einer der dinge
über die wir in der cdu csu
arbeitsgruppe außenpolitik gerade
aktuell darüber nachdenken haben wir
wirklich schon im bereich der
sanktionspolitik das äußerste gezogen
die jetzigen sanktionen würden
vermutlich recht stark
aber das zeigt dass sanktionen eben
tatsächlich ein wirksames instrument
sind warum dann nicht auch
dann noch
eine schippe drauflegen
verglichen mit der im kalten krieg
würden sie sagen das ist vergleichbar
oder heute nochmal um einiges
gefährlicher
es ist glaube ich schwer vergleichbar
aber konkret bezogen auf das handeln der
heute russischen führung und das
gespiegelt auf die sowjetunion
ich glaube dass ein politbüro der kpd su
eine solche entwicklung nicht zugelassen
hätte also ich glaube dass ein politbüro
an einer stelle wo sich jetzt quasi
der/die und studierte home der
unschlagbarkeit der russischen
streitkräfte in wenigen tagen auf der
straße in der ukraine auflöst wo die
gesamte welt sich gegen gegen russland
wendet wenn wenn die führung kollektiv
in der hand eines teams lege glaube ich
wäre es
wahrscheinlicher dass dieses team die
entwicklung stoppt und den
verantwortlichen entsprechend ersetzt
als das gegenwärtig im kreml es und wenn
sie so wollen es ist damit jetzt
eigentlich gefährlicher als es insoweit
nur die aussichten die haben wir derzeit
haben sind äußerst düster wir müssen uns
auf ganz ganz schlimme bilder aus der
ukraine vorbereiten die über das
hinausgehen was uns die letzten tage
erreicht hat die flüchtlings
perspektiven die zahlen haben sie
mitbekommen werden vom hc bereits hoch
gesetzt auf bis zu zehn millionen jetzt
die ukraine hat 40 millionen einwohner
das würde bedeuten dass 25 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung dieses land verlassen
müssen wir müssen ganz besonders
vorsichtig sein und aufpassen dass wir
nicht in den nato bündnisfall
hineinkommen das würde einen
europaweiten krieg zur folge haben putin
scheint entschlossen zu sein das
durchzuziehen gestern das gespräch
zwischen ihm und vladimir putin
wladimir putin das gespräch hat
aufgezeigt dass er offensichtlich zum
äußersten bereit ist wenn die duma jetzt
auch noch das kriegsrecht verhängt in
russland dann ist toll und tür geöffnet
wir haben 6000 verhaftete personen in
russland die zahl steigt an sämtliche
unabhängige berichterstattung es
ausgeschaltet das zeigt alles nicht in
eine gute zukunft und wir müssen jetzt
kühlen kopf behalten in allem was wir
tun und darauf achten dass wir als
bundesrepublik in der nato nicht in
einen krieg der ganz europa entzünden
würdet hineingezogen werden das ist
eigentlich die realität vor der wir
momentan stehen es geht momentan nicht
mehr darum in irgendeiner weise durch
verhandlungen irgendwas zu erreichen
putin hat diese de facto ausgeschlossen
und dementsprechend müssen wir uns für
alles rüsten vielen dank
soweit also die aussenpolitiker vor der
sitzung des auswärtigen ausschusses da
war ja sehr viel drin 1 ist deutlich
geworden vor allem die union dringt
jetzt darauf dass russland komplett aus
wirft ausgeschlossen wird die sanktionen
reichen nicht aus die russische
wirtschaft bekommt immer noch sehr viel
geld durch die europäer durch
deutschland aber auch durch amerika eben
die energielieferungen müssen
unterbrochen werden das ist die
forderung der cdu csu norbert röttgen
der außenpolitiker hat das für die
cdu/csu hier auch gerade noch einmal
bestätigt dass man das fordert wir haben
es gehört von michael roth am anfang er
sieht bessere chancen darin möglichst
einen vermittler einzuschalten wollte
dann nicht so ganz recht mit der sprache
raus auf angela merkel da die richtige
person für wäre ja also und insgesamt
wurde davor gewarnt eben überall in
einen atomkrieg herein zu schliddern
aber das heft des handelns haben die
nato staaten und die europäer nicht so
sehr in der hand sondern das geschieht
ja gerade in der ukraine und in der tat
das atomkraftwerk das muss man noch mal
ganz klar sagen ist eben doch zum glück
nicht getroffen worden es ist keine
strahlung wohl ausgetreten insofern sind
wir da noch einmal ein an einer
katastrophe vorbeigeschrammt aber in der
tat muss man sich auch hier die frage
stellen wenn das ganze sich noch
eskaliert wie kann man den russischen
präsidenten überhaupt noch aufhalten
und da ist die frage warum wir
eigentlich immer noch gas und kohle aus
russland beziehen eine gerechtfertigte
frage trifft damit der wirtschaft in
russland zu schaden wenn man aus wirft
die russen rauswirft das ist der ansatz
der vielleicht noch zieht denn diese
sanktionsmöglichkeiten hat man noch weil
man eben gar nicht komplett in allen
bereichen den zahlungsverkehr mit den
russen unterbrochen hat diese
möglichkeit ist noch da und wird
sicherlich in den nächsten stunden und
tagen auch in europa diskutiert werden
und damit zurück zu ines arland wir
sagen ganz herzlichen dank gehört ja
auch im fall war für ihre informationen
hintergründe und einschätzungen an
diesem freitagnachmittag von der
sondersitzung des auswärtigen
ausschusses des deutschen bundestages
sie werden diese vorgänge in berlin
weiter für uns begleiten